[Musique]
alors attention on va voir on a préparé
vous aimeriez une roue et vous allez
voir qui vous à les imiter à chaque fois
c'est parti
la battle d'imitation attention alors
que c'est une bataille là donc philippe
lellouche donc patrick bruel contre fifi
lachaud qui va imiter van damme
citadelle d'imitation elle n'est pas du
tout trucs et la roumanie ne réserve pas
de moi qui rêve depuis longtemps parce
que tu peux faire patrick bruel qui
reprend une chanson de charles aznavour
ah oui il a fait les ennuis mokolo hills
avant ce ventre alourdi de free les
bateaux est ce que tu peux faire à la
bourre qui me font elles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il peut le faire
rien pour les plus jeunes qui nous
regardent bourvil c'est comme fifi voilà
et bachir accusé comme mac os c'était
ici van damme
c'est à toi c'est horrible je sais pas
le faire mais oui c'est ça j'ai déjà
perdu ceni faire le grand écart ni
limitée mathieu remplacer que boulou gfr
en effet jonathan pedneault pas s'il
fait beau je me faut changer les images
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en effet tu peux le faire fait colonne
est même pas une phrase il en a
l'habitude non mais c'est le petit
mousse dans est-ce que tu peux faire
j'ai pas compris suis désolé là on doit
dire qu'il ya mieux fait bruel des
doigts que tu peux faire beaucoup
attention du patrimoine
[Musique]
[Rires]
ouais je donne quand même le point s'il
pleut c'est très bien aussi un de ces
battles deuxième battle je rappelle que
la route n'est pas truquée awesso zidane
en fait chacun seul côté de la rouquette
inquiète alors on va démarrer pas vous
l'a dit il face à ségolène royal
bon choix ouais bonsoir à tous et très
heureuse d'être avec vous ce soir
spécialement vous c'est qui abrutissent
et les enfants les adultes c'est un
abêtissement sans fin et on vous aime
pour ça merci sega l'ami vous émissions
sont magnifiques coloré avec des invités
monnerville
mais on parle pas de sécu et ça c'est
pas bon alors 150 ingénieurs de q&a
c'est vrai oui c'est ça asie c'est une
fille à rentrer dans un sex shop ai dit
tu auras le sextoy rose la joie aussi de
gros en noir est le plus gros en rouge
et les mecs 10 pour les deux premiers
pas de problème pour les secteurs je
demande au patron total alors cidade jeu
yaya ya pas si tu l'as déjà fait ou pas
du tout mais un jour je suis trop timide
c'est pas un peu l'accent du midi comme
ça va c'est pas moi yema low cost comme
ça je vais te près de rodez et le sage
les vieillards dans la rue qui est rodez
c'est en voiture j'ai vu avec des
enfants il ce n'est une porte qui a vu
jordan mais tournant s'est paumé live
est une maison à peu perdu et et voilà
c'est pas malien est un délit et quelque
chose il ya une belle tentative était
belle du niveau l'accord soit quatre
mois après son côté jeu truqué
ah ouais d'accord
ah oui ah oui d'accord donc ludivine
c'est l'idiot et moi je dois faire jean
luc reichmann toi c'est pas tilté des
jeunes tâche du calaisis si tellement
contente d'être là ne partez pas à ces
lésions historico
giummo frère elle est en race à l'abus
elle a appris que moi ce que j'adore
c'est la photo de c'est un photo cyril
là c'est vraiment la photo qui aurait eu
si tu faisais l'immobilier en fait
[Applaudissements]
dans ce gala ildiko la cigale et vous
n'avez pas de vis-à-vis il ya un énorme
potentiel
la limitation à huy c'est la question
que la question
la question coquine
[Musique]
déjà fait tonne badaboum rac peut
travailler attentats candidat s'était il
va re sonné chantal est ce que ça
bossait sur l'anecdote aussi un peu
valbuena quand ils jouent au foot parce
que c'est l'herbe qui lui chatouiller
couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi ce que je sais c'est dur si vous
fermez les yeux le public est juif
on va ce sera dans les bacs c'est un
playback et ferme les yeux je dois
trouver
je sais que c'est difficile peut-être on
revient là dessus on laisse du temps la
régie mais on peut pas trouver une image
de zidane qui en train de parler à sa
place on coupe le son est la grille
chantal fait la voix la vanille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la 23e minute assuré ce matin
j'aime bien j'ai bien j'espère que ça va
retomber à gad elmaleh
nicolas sarkozy doit me faire je sais
pas si un passif on va démarrer par toi
basilicate je n'ai jamais fait vas-y met
alors à temps mais je suis embêté parce
qu'il le fait tellement bien philippe
aymond tapis facteurs après je vais
faire il a fait des trucs de quoi dire
mais je vais fort de la classe
je vais faire la version moins de fêtes
tandis reggae du maroc s'est inscrit
comme assia c'est terrible parce que je
sais pas bien le faire il le fait
tellement de l'arête de foot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cyril hanouna
c'est d'abord un plaisir d'être ici
cette émission c'est très bien une
émission qui est que le dit
personnellement l'ouverture aux autres
je sais pas et je vais vous dire
monsieur hanouna il ya plein d'endroits
où j'ai pas forcément mis les pieds
faire content que venir vous voir pour
deux raisons fiona je vais vous dire
c'est quand on a peur du vent monte pas
en haut de l'arbre
et là moi j'ai envie de venir dans une
émission les gens vous regardent
ouais c'est tout voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors que j'ai jamais fait non plus déjà
jouer les cons s'est jamais fait bon
déjà tintin même type que sarkozy c'est
vrai c'est toujours comme ça brouille
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là
ah ouais bof
c'est ça
et il le fait sans péter les séries je
sens que la basse apple non mais c'est
quoi on abat c'est très très fort de
quoi mais mais mais on aurait dû
demander aux gens qu'ils qui vous savez
imiter cet après midi à des gens ton
équipe qui sont venues de tous bords qui
t'ont 10 mai s'ils savent pas imiter la
personne qui en veut tu as dit on s'en
fout ils vont le faire quand même merci
alors je le dis jamais on s'en fout
m'arrête syrie alors passionné enfin
vincent pons atout minceur pour le fait
chacun mais là pardon ça tourne sept
russes alors votre meilleure imitation
par exemple que chantal ce sera dit dan
voilà qui s'est invité d'autres
alors attention aux démarches à l'oms
vas-y alors je passe mon tour pour des
raisons techniques
d'accord il s'est amélioré à dalida
vas-y il venait d'avoir 18 ans il était
beau comme aller ensemble
c'est en fait je change pas de
l'habitation dans la plainte
je suis pas
[Applaudissements]
la pendule de l'entrisme s'est arrêté
sur midi jeudi de tragique
my back attention on m'a dit tous de
clara morgane phase i am a franchi un
paradis mercury je sais faire personne
là c'est pas fait du mieux que tu n'iras
pas ce que c'est
gad pas meilleur est allé à meilleurs
sites à leur nom mais les spécialistes
préféré et li et kim raconte souvent il
adorait cette balise et c'est rebecca et
sarah sont sur un bol par toutes les
deux équipes n'a pas beaucoup de
mouvements et ben se rapproche et
pillent elle commence à parler de leur
intimité tu vois et voilà il y en a une
qui tue 10 et sarah louise y dis moi
j'vais pas de toi à ton mari quand tu
fais l'amour tu le parcours à l'automne
dit m
et ma foi ça dépend s'ils m'appellent
sur l'importance je leur ai pas envie
sur la raison tu peux pas le faire après
diane socialistes devront couper mais
chantal voudraient l'imiter comprendriez
chantal tadec te fais super bien en fait
dans le privé alors si c'est vas-y vas-y
fais très bien à vous même physiquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais pourquoi tout me fait comme un
singe cbi sont ses mots ses blessures je
me semble ici c'est comme être mis en
relation géniale idée
vas-y oui c'est pas vrai c'est la
musique que j'aime
[Musique]
khaled al idée je fais très bien failli
être basique à j'en ai un
après j'en ai un j'ai dû hediger tetris
au jeu vaut mieux que tout ça baros on
démarre au mono
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
duris pis alors garde à quelqu'un
moi j'en ai un mais les plus jeunes qui
sont devant leur télé il faut leur dire
qu'ils étaient michel jonasz c'est le
jeune a 16 ans et la boîte de jazz est
là aussi je vais la refaire passe pas
sympa pour michel quand même pas ça sur
moi j'en ai un cyril oui c'est quoi
michel jonasz
j'adore ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est bien
[Rires]
mais chantal voulant faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
je te jure je me suis retourné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est où mais franchement pour moi le
vainqueur de bord on est tous d'accord
ici ses limites
je suis désolé ma chérie mais je pense
que là à marcher sur les plates-bandes
c'est surtout quand elle fait les gens
disent ils sont bientôt les émetteurs
non émergents ont tourné ensemble on a
tourné avec clowns et je me cachais
comme claude souvent le donnent les
loges
l'ordre est lui qui a réussi vous pouvez
pas peut pas le faire tout les deux
temps dans ce qu'on peut faire de
vachement mieux je vais te dire un truc
c'est par exemple chantal elle vient là
tu veux on va se dire une phrase et moi
je me cache derrière et en fait je le
fais
c'est chabal à d'autres partis moi
j'aimerais bien voir des émissions alors
vas-y donc je te fais des trucs abattu
sa femme à moi j'aimerais bien le cul et
[Musique]
ses jeux fait du playback on essaye
bonsoir mon cher ami ou parent et
d'ailleurs je voudrais enfin des devoirs
il t'as pas besoin de te matin
[Rires]